Speaker 1: I do need to start today with an
apology for everything I've ever said on the
show that has upset somebody.
No, I'm kidding.
I want to apologize because I did a little
bit of a cleaning in the studio.
You could call it sort of a bleaching of sorts.
And I didn't realize that two furniture elements
that are normally separated where my microphone
is connected to something that is nowhere
near me just so I can't inadvertently create
any gunk in the audio to think two elements
were touching that should not have been touching
the last two days.
And I didn't even realize that I was regularly
creating a sort of above noise with the microphone.
People sent me, as you can imagine, extremely
polite messages about it and I've resolved
it, OK, I've resolved it.
So I do want to apologize for that.
But let's not dwell on the negative.
We are really starting to get to the next
phase, which I would believe to be the end
phase of the coronavirus pandemic as cases
are now down nearly 90 percent in the United
States, deaths are down nearly 85 percent.
But but but vaccination continues to slow
down, as there are now way more vaccines in
the US than the number of people that seem
to want them, at least relatively quickly,
which is sad.
And we're going to talk about that.
Much of that lack of demand is because of
Republicans.
This isn't a bipartisan thing.
Four percent of Democrats don't want the vaccine.
Forty one percent of Republicans don't want
the vaccine, as we discussed yesterday.
Let's go through the case and death numbers
as we now have them.
Cases in the United States peaking in mid-January,
around two hundred and fifty five thousand
a day now down to an average of 32000 a day.
That is a decline of about 87 percent from
that pandemic peak.
There are some states where cases are there,
not literally zero, but they are almost statistically
zero places like California that now have
really, really low rates.
And they're continuing down as more and more
people get vaccinated.
In terms of deaths, things are not yet looking
as good deaths lag changes in cases by about
three to four weeks.
But nevertheless, deaths are now down about
82 percent from a pandemic peak in late January.
We were at thirty four fifty a day.
That's like 9/11, plus 10 percent every day
in deaths in late January.
We are now down to just a hair over 600 deaths
a day.
Still way too high to be calling this anything
close to over.
But the right direction continues and that
direction is down.
Now, one factor that is slowing down the decline
is that fewer and fewer people are getting
vaccinated each day.
This is not because there aren't enough vaccines
or not enough appointments.
Just about every state, many pharmacy chains,
chains, many locations have switched to just
show up.
No appointment needed.
Just get over here and we'll give you a vaccine.
We have more than enough vaccines to go around.
We have vaccines here like countries around
the world are dreaming of having.
That's not an exaggeration.
But forty one percent of Republicans and twenty
four percent of all Americans don't want the
vaccine.
And so after peaking at about three point
three million doses per day in early April,
we have seen almost a 50 percent decline to
now just one point eight million doses per
day.
This is embarrassing.
Look around the world.
Countries around the world are doing everything
they can to get vaccines.
There are countries that are happy to get
half a million vaccines.
We have millions and millions of them just
sitting around ready.
And we have millions and millions of people
saying, no, I don't want to get one.
The cases and the deaths would decline way
more quickly if more people got vaccinated.
Just think we're vaccinating about half of
the number we were vaccinating a month ago.
Each day we could be seeing cases decline
significantly faster.
If we just got back to where we were three
point three million vaccines per day, we could
open everything sooner and more safely if
more people got vaccinated.
Now, what's going on globally?
Because the US led from the standpoint of
bad early in the pandemic, we are now leading
from the standpoint of good in terms of the
vaccination.
But the U.S. is not the world.
What's going on with global numbers?
The good news is that global cases and global
deaths are now clearly starting to come down.
Ten days ago, it looked like they were leveling
off.
But where will things go?
Globally, cases peaked at about eight hundred
and thirty thousand cases per day in later
April.
We're now down to about six hundred and sixty
five thousand a day.
It's an outrageous number, but it's down.
20 percent from the peak, that's good global
deaths similarly to the picture in the US,
global deaths are declining, but lagging the
case decline.
Global deaths peaked at about 14000 a day
back in January.
Can you imagine?
Almost got back there in April and we are
now down to about 12000 deaths a day.
That's a decline of 15 percent from the peak.
But there is a long way to go globally.
And part of why it's so depressing to know
that we have the vaccines for everyone.
But to see in the United States people opting
out is that the vaccines are why the US is
doing better and better.
This is a very similar thing to the measles
anti vaccine, and it's depressing.
Doesn't even really cut it.
You have measles and TIV actors who say who
dies of measles?
Why would I go and get my kid vaccinated for
measles?
The reason almost no one dies of measles is
the vaccination campaign has been so effective
and the vaccine is so effective.
Were it not for that, then people would be
dying of measles.
People are saying some cases are going down,
this is ending.
I don't need to get the vaccine.
But the reason why they're going down is we
have so many vaccines.
It's a privilege to have access to so many
vaccines.
An incredible headline.
Multiple states reported zero covid deaths
on single days over the last week for the
first time in months.
This includes Arizona, Minnesota, Massachusetts,
Maryland and others.
Now, of course, weekend reporting can throw
off the meaning of any single day's data,
but the averages are declining, things are
opening.
And that is all great.
Just go and get vaccinated.
It's free.
You just show up.
There's a vaccine available and maybe this
will be more of an incentive for people to
get vaccinated, although I think the people
not getting vaccinated don't care about this.
The European Union has announced hours ago
they will be opening to vaccinated Americans.
Let's talk about that next